so I hope you had a wonderful
Thanksgiving Democrats are rushing to
defend sexual harassers Republicans are
rushing to defend sexual molesters and
the New York Times actually did
something right so everything is awesome
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
ah yes just when you thought things
couldn't get any worse we came back from
Thanksgiving vacation I hope you had a
wonderful Thanksgiving we had a
wonderful Thanksgiving at the Shapiro
household actually went up to Big Bear
for the weekend which was just awesome
but I hope that you did something fun
with your family as well a lot to get to
because the news doesn't stop just
because the world seems to over
Thanksgiving Day weekend before we get
to any of the brand-new news first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at ring.com so rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer today over a million
people use the amazing ring video
doorbell we are some of those people and
we are out of town we know when people
are ringing our doorbell because it
rings directly through to my phone and I
can see who it is that is ringing my
doorbell which is great because if
someone wants to break into my house
normally what they do is they're going
to ring the doorbell see if somebody's
home and then they break in if nobody
answers so you can answer it and then
they're not going to know whether you're
home or whether or not and they're not
going to break in this is one of the
purposes of having the ring video
doorbell it also makes sense if you have
an annoying neighbor and you don't
actually want that person to come into
your house ring video doorbell is very
useful for that as well right now they
also have the ring floodlight can and
they are extending their levels of
security to the rest of your home just
like rings amazing doorbell floodlight
Kim is a motion-activated camera and
floodlight that connects right to your
phone with HD video and two-way audio
but lets you know the moment anyone
steps onto your property you can see and
speak to visitors you can even set off
an alarm right from your phone so nobody
is going to be threatening your property
ever again ring floodlight offers the
ultimate in home security
again save up to one hundred and fifty
dollars off a ring of security kit when
you go to ring accom / bend that's
ring.com
/ menu at one hundred and fifty bucks
off the ring of security k which is a
solid deal ring comm / bend that is ring
calm / bend
make sure that you go and check it out
ring comm / Bend use the slash bend for
the discount and to make sure they know
that we sent you okay so I want to
contrast today situations in which
Americans feel that sexual harassment
mala station are just wrong wrong wrong
and E wrong wrong and situations in
which apparently we don't care anymore
so here's the situation in which we feel
that it is wrong wrong wrong and E wrong
wrong if you have somebody who's
applying to your college football
coaching position then even the mildest
suspicion they may have covered up for
sexual molestation means that you cannot
get the job I speak of course of Greg
Schiano Greg Schiano it was was about to
be hired at the University of
Tennessee's the Ohio State defense
coordinator and Schiano has been very
successful in that position he was about
to sign a contract at the University of
Tennessee to take over their head
coaching position but then a lot of
people started to protest and they
started protest because Greg Schiano was
working over at Penn State when Jerry
Sandusky the then defensive coordinator
was stooping little boys in the in the
showers and when the Paterno Joe Paterno
was allegedly allowing that to occur or
at least not doing enough to stop it and
there was one allegation by then it
might McQueary who was one of the guys
working on the defensive staff that he
had heard through the grapevine that
Schiano had seen Sandusky molesting a
kid and done nothing about it now that
allegation was unsubstantiated it was
denied by Schiano it was denied also by
another member of the defense of
coordinating staff who supposedly
McQuarrie had heard this from in the
first place so this is really kind of
dicey stuff to begin with but even the
implication that Schiano must have known
about it or may have known about it
meant that the people at University of
Tennessee went nuts so all of
Tennessee's major politicians said you
can't hire Schiano they have a big rock
at University of Tennessee I know about
it cuz I was just visiting University of
Tennessee at Knoxville they've this big
rock where you can paint messages on the
rock and one of the things they painted
was Schiano covered up child rape at
Penn State so they ended up withdrawing
their offered to drag Schiano because
obviously we don't want people who are
alleged to have covered up child
molestation no matter how weak the
allegation coaching a major college
football program he should have run for
Congress that would have been a lot
better for him if he had run for
Congress because the Democrats who spent
the last month saying that it's time to
finally wipe out sexual harassment it's
time to finally wipe out sexual abuse
and you know where we should start we
should start with the Alabama Senate
race let's start with that kiddy porn
guy Roy Moore let start with that guy
let's start with him you know we're so
into the anti sexual harassment campaign
now say the Democrats were even willing
to throw the desiccated corpse of Bill
Clinton under the bus he's no longer
useful to us we'll just take that
skeleton and toss it right under the
grinding wheels of that bus time for him
to go Teddy Kennedy that dudes been
bloated and dead for a long time so if
we have to say some bad things about
Teddy Kennedy okay well we will set a
new standard a brand new standard and
now the day of light is coming and there
will be no more sexual harassment
there'll be no more sexual abuse well
finally come to a conclusion in this
great saga of women being victimized
throughout the United States
in positions of power well that lasted
for like a week
so congratulations Democrats your moral
stand lasted for having less than a week
actually because first there were
allegations about senator Al Franken and
then there were allegations about John
Conyers so the let's start with the
Conyers allegations because this is
truly stunning stuff so John Conyers is
an eighty eight-year-old Congress person
he is apparently senile there there
reports that he had literally walked
into meetings in his pajamas John
Conyers he's not been around for quite a
while he was apparently a a guy who
sexually harassed women many years ago
as well at least those were the
allegations in any case it has now come
out that there was a settlement that
Conyers made with a former member of his
office in which she accused him
basically of propositioning her and when
she refused he fired her was basically
the allegations ended up settling out
for like 30 grand there's also a lawsuit
that have been filed against Conyers
there was an on-the-record allegation by
the Washington Post as a big report by
The Washington Post all of this happens
and Conyers is 88 years old now make no
mistake this is what's astonishing okay
so yeah I'll talk about Roy Moore in a
little while but let's just put it this
way the Republicans have said Roy Moore
can't lose that seat why can't Roy Moore
to lose that seat because if you go from
52 to 51 votes in the Senate it's gonna
be very difficult to pass anything plus
what happens if there's a Supreme Court
vacancy and you need that vote so a
Senate seat is super important and right
now if more we're to lose he's in the
middle of an election cycle a Democrat
would take that seat and the Democrat
would then be able to vote against the
priorities of Republicans okay it's an
argument I don't think it's the world's
strongest argument but it is an argument
this is the binary argument we saw
during the 2016 election it's the exact
same argument they were having it again
I didn't buy then I don't buy it now but
okay let's assume that that's an
argument I'll tell you what's not an
argument let's say that Roy Moore were a
sitting u.s. senator and let's say the
governor of his state were a Republican
and now he could be thrown out of office
and the Republican governor would simply
appoint a Republican replacement or
let's say that there was a
congressperson a Republican Congress
person who was in the midst of a sex
scandal and that person would be thrown
out of office there'd be a special
election it's a very Republican
districts and a Republican would be
elected to replace that person in all
likelihood wouldn't that sort of take
away the the IVA even the argument that
there's a binary choice well this is
what's so incredible about what the
Democrats are doing Republicans maybe
are
about more you can't have Doug Jones in
there again I think that I don't want
suck Jones in there either I think the
moral choice in Alabama is to set it out
or write somebody in instead of Roy
Moore but at least there's an argument
that the Senate seats important there is
no argument that Al Franken Senate seat
is important because it's not there's a
Democratic governor of Minnesota right
now there's no argument that John
Conyers his seat is important he's in
like a d-plus 1000 district John Conyers
has been reelected for 22 straight terms
I believe the guy runs like a medieval
fiefdom okay if he's thrown out guess
what a Democrat will replace him
Democrats still refuse to throw Conyers
under the bus this is amazing stuff it
just demonstrates that all this talk
about sexual harassment sexual assault
sexual misconduct it's all a bunch of
hooey when it comes from politicians
they're all lying they say they pretend
to care about this stuff they do not
care about this stuff one iota and the
proof is coming from your very very
feminist House Minority Leader Nancy
Pelosi Nancy Pelosi
then came out and she called John she's
asked about John Conyers and whether
John Conyers should go and remember
Nancy Pelosi is the first female Speaker
of the House she held up the big gavel
she brought in all of her grandkids the
ones who had not been aborted and they
all stood around her and it was all just
glorious and wonderful
she's such a feminist icon Nancy Pelosi
now she specifically asked about John
Conyers who has many allegations of
sexual harassment against him by Chuck
Todd and here is Nancy Pelosi's answer
you said there's now a zero tolerance
John Conyers what does that mean for him
right now let's say it around we are
strengthened by due process just because
someone is accused you and it was that
one accusation is it - I think there has
to be John Conyers is an icon in our
country if he has done a great deal to
protect women violence against women Act
which the left wing right wing is now
quoting me as praising him for his work
on that and he did great work on that
but the fact is as John reviews his case
which he knows which I don't I believe
he will do I believe that he was excuse
me may I finished my sense that he will
do with the right thing you'll do the
right thing so here's what he did he
stepped down from the House Judiciary
Committee which the Democrats wanted him
to do anyway because they want somebody
who is not senile in charge of that
committee but when she says we don't
know the accusers how many there are
what they've said well we know there's a
settlement we know there was a
Washington Post story full of
allegations we
you're calling on Roy Moore to step down
from his Alabama Senate race over very
you know over allegations that are
quote-unquote similarly vague because
they're not vague right Nancy Pelosi
great feminist hero says John Conyers an
icon II must a and then she goes even
further she defends Franken she defends
Bill Clinton and then she calls Roy
Moore a child molester I don't know how
you can hold a standard of evidence that
says that Al Franken is innocent Bill
Clinton is innocent Roy Moore is guilty
that standard of evidence does not exist
obviously it is a generational change
but let me just say the concern that we
had then was that they were impeaching
the President of the United States and
for something that had nothing to do
with the performance of his duties and
trying to take him out for that reason
why do you think the reaction was
different by women on Bill Clinton and I
say that because it does seem as if
frankly when you watch some of the
reactions by the president in defending
Roy Moore or at least overlooking the
allegations against Roy Moore that were
you putting politics ahead of your
personal disgust no but we're talking
about a child molester Oh President
Clinton was accused of being a sexual
predator well I mean or even rape why
don't we talk instead about how we go
forward nobody is proud of President
Clinton's behavior at the time why don't
we talk about how we go forward because
you haven't gone forward you're
defending John Conyers and Al Franken
right now forget about 20 years ago now
write all these Democrats who are now
saying oh I we would have been in favor
of Bill Clinton's impeachment they're
full of absolute crap because now they
have the opportunity not only to do this
but to do it without any sort of
political repercussion that's what's
truly astonishing to me right the
political loyalty runs so deep in
Washington DC the partisan tribalism
runs so deep in Washington DC it doesn't
even matter if you're gonna lose
something now I was under the weird
misimpression over the last couple weeks
that all of this was about losing a seat
or losing political power it's not even
about that it's about pure partisan
loyalty it's about John Conyers has a D
by his name it doesn't matter if he'd be
replaced by another person with a D by
his name so long as he has the D by his
name Nancy Pelosi will stand by his side
she'll stand by Bill Clinton's side she
has no good answers to these questions
if they want Roy Moore elected there's
no better way of getting Roy Moore
elected to the United States Senate than
for Democrats to do exactly what they
this weekend it gets even worse and I'll
show you talk about it in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriots supply so
listen the government recommends that in
case of natural disaster you have some
food on hand in your house that can take
you through a period that could be
pretty brutal here in California there
been reports about some activity along
the San Andreas Fault if God forbid
there were to be a major earthquake the
government recommends that you're
supposed to have a certain amount of
food available in your house so you
don't have to run out to the grocery
store or in case emergency services
can't get to you that's why you need to
speak with my friends over at my Patriot
supply you can get their 102 serving
survival food kit for just 99 bucks it
includes breakfasts lunches and dinners
it is shipped to your home office your
home or your office for free order a kit
for yourself now call eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen 888
eight oh three fourteen thirteen or go
online to prepare with been calm prepare
with been calm again the emergency food
lasts for like twenty five years in
storage so you buy it once you forget
about it and then when there's an
emergency you're glad that you did you
spent ninety nine bucks and have one
hundred and two servings of survival
food for just $99 really good deal for
making sure your family is preserved in
safety again eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 or prepare with been Commons
prepare with been calm yeah another one
of these Democrats demonstrating her
hypocrisy is a woman named Jackie Speier
Jackie Speier is a Democratic
Representative and Miss Speier is she
has said that there are multiple sexual
predators basically in Congress and John
Conyers is not one of them she has said
that she know about all of the people
know who these people are she's from
California here is her discussing John
Conyers
right here's what she had to say about
John Conyers the other day do we
actually have a clip or it's just the
graphic okay so here's what she actually
said she said quote I think the
allegations are very serious and that's
why there's the ethics committee needs
to move forward very swiftly now wait
years but very swiftly staff up if
necessary to determine whether or not
those allegations are accurate if
they're accurate I do believe
congressman Conyers should step down
okay the if they're accurate routine the
if they're accurate routine basically
suggest that now there needs to be a
full trial before we decide in public
affairs whether or not somebody needs to
step down if that were the case Bill
Clinton was never convicted of anything
Hillary Clinton was never convicted of
anything David Vitter was never
convicted of anything you know that all
these all these people Anthony Weiner at
the time he
design had not been convicted of
anything that's not how politics works
politics is not about the idea that you
have to go through a full due process
trial that's what you do to avoid prison
politics is about who do you want
representing you and if we're all gonna
new head now have the standard that you
have to be convicted of a crime in order
for you to be removed from office then I
guess that's our standard from now on
but it just means that our politicians
are basically going to be worse and
worse people it's pretty astonishing
right and Conyers of course has said
that he'll step aside the Judiciary
Committee it means nothing again for the
for the tenth time John Conyers leaving
would mean nothing to the Democrats John
Conyers his district is heavily
Democratic now yeah but that's not the
only instance of the Democrats doing
this over the weekend over the weekend
the Democrats came out and defended Al
Franken so Al Franken has come out and
he said he's ashamed but he's not
stepping down he's ashamed of his
behavior he said that he can still be
effective he said quote I've let a lot
of people down and I'm hoping I can make
it up to them and gradually regain their
trust right this is what he said on
Sunday by phone he said I'm looking
forward to getting back to work tomorrow
so no he's not stepping down it doesn't
matter there's an actual picture of him
trying to grab a sleeping woman's
breasts it doesn't matter that many many
women have now come out and said they
grabbed their butts he says by the way
his defense of himself is that he's a
hugger that he's a hugger did his hands
hug asses I'm confused here is Al
Franken defending himself
you know III can't say that that hasn't
happened I take thousands and thousands
of pictures we sometimes in crowded and
chaotic situations I can't say I haven't
done that and I I'm I am very sorry if
these women experience that okay
experience they didn't experience it you
grab their butts like dude you know what
you know it takes a lot of pictures in
crowded situations right hear me okay I
do it all the time
Mathis my producer can attest to this
okay I do this all the time I'm in major
crowds all the time taking pictures of
lots of people including many young
women not once has my hand gravitated
toward their posterior you know why
because that's sexual assault you're not
supposed to grab people on their butts
you stupid piece of crap okay and here
he is saying I'm sorry if they
experienced that as though it was like a
hurricane it just sort of came along and
swept
well I'm sorry they had to experience
that inevitability of life which is my
hand on there but my bad
hey you you don't fire the shoulders
from the butt by the way it's a long way
from the butt okay when I take nothing
not to give like basic the knee bone is
connected to the shin bone but when I
say a picture with somebody and my hand
is up here at their shoulder I have to
travel at least two feet downward to
reach an ass okay but apparently al
franken's hand is so driven by gravity
downward right is the heaviest hand in
the world he just can't keep it up there
just slides down and then he says well
you know I'll apologize if these women
experienced anything it's just it's just
terrible I just can't you know but I'm
not stepping down now leaving or
anything and the Democrats are not gonna
force him to leave okay and the proof is
there it's all there it's pretty
astonishing so all that's happened in
our politics is that basically because
we're such partisan tribalist because
they're such loyalists now the way that
it works if you even issue the remotest
denial it doesn't matter if the denial
is credible or not it doesn't matter if
the denial is good then I'll can be the
stupidest denial that you ever heard of
none of it matters so long as you issue
any denial of any kind that gives
somebody a peg that they can hang their
hat on which suggests that we don't care
about this crap in the first place like
even President Trump like president
Trump over the weekend there's a report
out this is an astonishing report
there's a report out the President Trump
has been going around the last few
months
privately questioning from the
authenticity of the Access Hollywood
recording no I am not kidding you
remember in 2016 there was that famous
tape that came out of him saying he
grabbed lemon by the bleeps and they
wouldn't care because you're famous
right when you when you're famous I'll
let you do anything and there was a tape
of him talking to Billy Bush about this
apparently he's been going around
repeating a claim to advisors that it's
not even a real take that it was
manufactured okay so he's now created a
conspiracy theory about a conversation
in which he personally took place I'm
not joking this is the thing that
happened okay this is according to both
ABC News and the New York Times it's not
surprising because President Trump has a
unique capacity to convince himself of
virtually anything and any news that is
bad for him he calls fake news like you
know he tweeted out this is pretty
hilarious after him and he tweeted this
out just this morning quote we should
have a contest as to which of the
networks plus CNN and not including Fox
is the most dishonest corrupt and or
distorted in its political coverage of
your favorite president parentheses
me they are all bad winner to receive
all caps the fake news trophy come on
down done it okay he never gave up
actually being on a game show I do love
that he is restricting your choices here
to include CNN but not Fox because he
likes Fox and then I like that he has to
label it I like that he now calls
himself your favorite president I do
love that it's pretty spectacular and
then he has to and then he has to put in
parentheses me as though we were gonna
be unclear about who he was talking
about that we thought he was talking
about George Washington or Abraham
Lincoln that CNN and Fox had not been
covering George Washington or Abraham
Lincoln fairly I have to admit the guy I
don't know whether he's joking or not I
think he's like half joking here but
that's pretty funny stuff I mean that's
pretty funny it would be funnier if you
weren't the President of the United
States and you know had responsibilities
and everything I gave you if you're just
sort of a guy on Twitter but I guess
that's that's sort of what he considers
himself to be like this is it's pretty
amazing right I do love it but this is
how you wonder how we get to a point
where we can ignore plausible
allegations it's because this is what
people think of the news Trump is
actually not wrong when he says this is
how people think of the news the left
thinks of Fox News is a propaganda
outlet the right things of CNN is a
propaganda outlet therefore any
allegations focused on by either one of
them is going to be considered
propaganda so long as it hurts your side
and this brings us finally in at last to
Roy Moore so well the Democrats have
been working very hard to give up the
moral high ground for no apparent can't
I mean this is how bad they are it's a
thank God for Republicans the Democrats
are so bad at this I mean truly
horrifying at this that they go through
this whole routine with Roy Moore and
then in order to save Al Franken and
John Conyers both people who would be
replaced by Democrats they decide to
undermine any moral credibility they had
Roy Moore is gonna survive not only as
we're more gonna survive I would think
he's gonna win now I would be very
surprised if Roy Moore does not when his
Alabama Senate race not because he
deserves to win the Alabama Senate race
but because the Democrats have set up a
standard right the Democrats have set up
a standard they set up in 1998 and they
they they look like they were moving
away from it and then they just hugged
it with both hands over the weekend
hug it with both hands on a woman's but
over the weekend the Democrats came out
and they basically said any Democrat
who's accused of anything we will defend
that's essentially what they say and so
the Republicans are now essentially
doing the same thing which is not a huge
surprise
right here's the RNC chair Rhonda
McDaniel Rhonda Rhonda McDaniel she
comes out and she says listen the voters
are gonna decide which is again a
cop-out right she could have some input
here but she's not going to because the
voters are going to decide the Alabama
voters are going to have to be the judge
and jury on this they're going to have
to look at the women that have come
forward with these very concerning
allegations and then what the judge is
putting forward and they're gonna have
to make a decision as to whether or not
they want him to represent their state
in the United States Senate okay and now
we know by the way that people will buy
into any denial because the Democrats
bought intending tonality so Nancy
Pelosi on national TV saying that she
doubts the women who accused John
Conyers even though there is a sign
settlement a sign settlement and still
she's saying that she doesn't believe
the accusers writerly she doesn't have
enough evidence to believe the accusers
so is it any wonder that were way more
isn't gonna back down and that he's
gonna send out his lawyers to say stuff
like this here's Roy Moore's lawyer
say there's campaign strategist saying
that they believe Roy Moore and all of
the women are lying all 9,000 women are
lying and all this Jerry Springer stuff
is over and I'm talking to all y'all
we're not gonna do this anymore as a
campaign so all you all you people run
around yelling stuff at judge Moore
asking these ridiculous question I'm the
chief political strategist and my advice
is every time they yell something like
that to you judge Moore or to the
campaign just think it's the Jerry
Springer Show don't answer it
judge Moore's answered all the questions
we believe judge Moore we don't believe
these women it's just that simple
and y'all can keep trotting them out if
you want to but we're not gonna talk
about that okay I'm getting this by the
way like when I hosted for Mark Levin
the day before Thanksgiving
virtually every caller agreed with this
lawyer agreed with the campaign guy here
that Roy Moore was innocent and all
these women relying and that all of the
stories were false I guess we this is
now the standard that we have which is
no standard at all for evidence okay
like I again I've explained time and
time again on the show I think that the
allegations are credible and and even
the bottom line is that any any argument
will now be made in order to find these
people Joel who is the who is
the editor-at-large I guess senior
editor at large now over a Breitbart my
former employer which has become just a
propaganda outlet for whichever chosen
candidate Breitbart and Steve ban and
decide is important today
Joel was was doing his his propaganda
work on CNN this morning talking about
how judge Roy Moore could have been
dating 16 year old and it was totally
fine because Ringo Starr or something
you know in 1973 Ringo Starr number one
on the Billboard charts with the song
age of 16 you're beautiful in your mind
and it was a remake of an earlier song
he was 30-something at the time singing
about a 16 year old you want to take
away Ringo Starr is you can't be serious
I mean you can't be sick you can't be
serious you're talking about these
series we leave that Ringo Starr's song
is supposed to be a nod towards allowing
30 year old men to prey on teenagers you
don't believe that Joel okay so two
things one the the original song was
written by the Sherman Brothers and it
was written for a teenager about other
teenagers so there are better examples
of this I mean if Joel wants to do this
we actually did a full deconstructing
the culture in which we cited song after
song last week of older men preying on
younger women so it rolls not wrong at
this exists in popular culture but the
question is why is that a defense of
more like I I use that in my
deconstructing the culture segment I use
that to talk about how depraved our
culture had become I didn't use that as
a defense of somebody doing it oh my
goodness but I guess this is this is
where we are I guess that's a defense
now ever everything is a defense now so
that's very exciting stuff I'm just glad
that I'm glad that we can't have people
who have vague allegations of covering
up for child molestation made about them
sitting as the head coach at University
of Tennessee because our moral standards
are so high but sitting in the United
States Senate different story or sitting
in the United States Senate even if they
be replaced by a member of their own
party different story yeah I think that
we may be toast here again I'm thinking
that the moral credibility of the
American people may be called me because
listen it's not about the people in
Congress anymore it's about us it's
about what we tolerate in the end we are
the voters what do we decide to tolerate
what do we decide is it okay for people
sitting there and if we have to lose a
race every so often in order for
everyone to have a better moral standard
maybe that's an important thing
maybe those moral standards are
important because the fact is that if
all we believe Congress is a series of
people who are gonna vote for us
regardless of character we're gonna have
bad people who are willing to betray our
interests okay bad people are bad people
I don't trust people about whom these
you wouldn't trust this person to
babysit your child I don't know why
you'd trust them
to implement all of your policy
decisions I guess this is the hard
divide that was made in the nineteen
nineties about Bill Clinton and I guess
we all buy the Bill Clinton school of
thought now we were gonna make noise
about how we didn't but apparently we
all do okay so before I go any further
and talk about the stupidity I'm a bunch
of people who are ripping into the New
York Times for what I thought was
actually a really interesting and well
done piece about white supremacists
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at stamps.com so we here
at the Ben Shapiro show use stamps calm
all the time that's because the post
office is great they're really efficient
but they're not as efficient as sitting
at your desk at your house and not
having to go stand in line at the post
office that means that you are able to
print out your postage at home they will
send you a scale so that you can
actually weigh your postage and No
except your packages and know exactly
how much postage is necessary they'll
send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact
postage it will even help you decide the
best class of mail every time stamps
calm we use stamps calm because again we
don't have time to run to the post
office right now you too can enjoy the
stamps calm service with a special offer
it includes a four week trial plus
postage and the digital scale without
long term commitments go to stamps calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Shapiro again
click on stamps calm type in the money
there's a microphone atop a page click
it and type in Shapiro and you'll get a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale without long term
commitments which is an awesome deal you
know before I get to this New York Times
piece I'm just gonna need to give you a
brief rundown on what's happening over
at the at the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau because this has
become an issue in the last couple of
hours basically here's the story
according to the Washington Post as a
Republican congressman Mick Mulvaney
called the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau a joke and said he wished it
didn't exist mainly cuz it's kind of a
joke and it shouldn't exist on Monday
Mulvaney showed up at the agency's DC
offices with the bag of doughnuts in a
new title boss but after a frantic
weekend of political and legal posturing
Mulvaney's arrival represented a new
escalation of tensions over who
ultimately will lead the agency a day
earlier
Leandre English filed suit claiming she
is the rightful Acting Director so
leadership of the agency was thrown into
doubt last Friday when which for Richard
Cordray stepped down as CFPB director
and said his chief of staff English
would temporarily replace him a few
hours later Trump named Mulvaney the
Office of Management and Budget Director
and longtime critic of the CFPB to do
the job okay let's put it this way this
is insane what Richard Cordray did here
and what Leandre English are doing here
it's crazy there are two bills that are
governing
okay bill number one was passed in 1998
and it says the president has the power
to fill all of these vacancies right in
1998 there's a bill specifically says
the president has the power to fill the
vacancy and then there is the dodd-frank
bill and dodd-frank bill says that the
director when he steps down can appoint
an interim acting director okay that may
be true but the president can trump that
if the president wants to fill the slot
because otherwise the person is not
subject to appointment the person is not
subject to senatorial go ahead otherwise
you have a completely unaccountable
bureaucrat appointing another
unaccountable bureaucrat that's not the
way that separation of powers work
there's an executive branch agency
either the person who is appointed has
to be appointed by the President and
approved by the Senate or it has to be
appointed by the president you don't
have executive Asian's executive branch
agencies that run independent of the
executive branch and the legislative
branch I mean I guess the contention
here is that Richard Cordray becomes his
magical own dictator that the minute
Richard Cordray steps into that office
now he has the power to appoint
successors and he gets to run the place
the way that he wants to run the place
that's not how this works I mean Richard
Cordray was appointed I believe by
President Obama was the idea and Richard
Cordray I mean this is a political stunt
there is no question that this is a
political stunt they could have fired
him they didn't fire him instead they
allowed him to step down but in stepping
down he decided to start a political
firefight because he wanted to make a
name for himself and run for governor of
Ohio is basically the idea again there's
nothing in law that allows Richard
Cordray Trump the president of the
United States
remember that originally Obama Obama
appointed Cordray by using an
unconstitutional recess appointment
Democrats threatened to change the
filibuster rules and Republicans
surrendered this is back in 2013 and
then in 2013 the Senate confirmed the
guy to a five-year term but this is
pretty cynical stuff the National Review
has a as a good piece by Ronald Rubin on
this and essentially what it says is
since 2010 Republicans have argued that
the CFPB's unique structure and
independent agency whose single director
the president can fire only four cause
with guaranteed funding through federal
reserve bank profits rather than the
congressional appropriation process is a
recipe for government abuse if not
unconstitutional Cordray proved them
right warned bill to Elizabeth
horn is the person who made these
changes through dodd-frank and court
very deployed it the bureau's powerful
media division dictated policy to its
regulatory professionals and
relentlessly exaggerated the agency's
achievements and daily press releases in
social media posts political operatives
used the CFPB's super independence to
Stonewall congressional subpoenas and
hide unethical investigation tactics
internal discrimination problems and
other inconvenient facts Republican
critics were dismissed as wall street
sycophants meanwhile millions of dollars
were diverted from the CFPB to
Democratic allies from 2014 to 22 2017
the bureau paid eleven million dollars a
year to rent office space in an Obama
fundraisers building they were allowed
to do this because they basically ran
the place like a fiefdom again and then
he entrenched with Cordray put a bunch
of Democratic employees in during the
first half of 2017 and then he awarded a
fifteen million dollar contract to
another one of Obama's friends he's been
doing all the stuff and then finally
Trump was gonna use the federal
vacancies Reform Act of 1998 that's what
I was referring to to appoint budget
director Mick Mulvaney to come in and
clean house at the CFPB
so instead Cordray resigned and then
appointed his own replacement he
appointed his chief of staff
the CFPB deputy director and they cited
language in the dodd-frank act that the
deputy director shall serve as acting
director in the absence or
unavailability of the director okay this
is not the same thing as he steps down
and you could that even the bill itself
doesn't say he can appoint his own
replacement it says that if he's absent
or unavailable like he's overseas or
something but there's no question that
that Trump is gonna win this thing in
court I mean if he doesn't win this
thing in court is just another example
of insane political activism on the part
of the courts which would not actually
be supremely surprising okay now
meanwhile the New York Times has been
accused of sympathizing with Nazis yes
really the left is now eating its own
which is somewhat delicious but I have
to say incredibly stupid I'm gonna talk
about that in just a second but first
we're gonna have to go over to you're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
get the daily wire subscription that
means that you get the rest of this show
live on video it means you get the rest
of the michael Mol's show live on beyond
the rest of the Andrew Clavin show live
on video it means that you get to be
part of our mailbag on Fridays it means
that when the Shapiro store comes and it
is coming you will get discounts at the
Shapiro ster
as well also if you've come in the
annual subscriber then you get this for
99 bucks a year you get all of that
which is cheaper than the monthly
subscription but you also get this the
greatest and all beverage vessels the
left dis tears hot or cold tumbler you
will never enjoy drinking anything as
much as you will enjoy drinking
beverages from this particular tumbler
which apparently grants immortality
I can't attest to that but I haven't
died yet so so far so good liberal
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr you
can get that with your annual
subscription as well if you just want to
watch the listens of the show later then
subscribe over at YouTube or SoundCloud
or iTunes subscribe over at YouTube
particularly cuz we have lots of the
video material that comes out on a
regular basis that you won't get if you
just subscribe it's SoundCloud or iTunes
but go over subscribe whatever your
podcast app we are available we are one
of the top podcast in the nation so make
sure you subscribe and leave us a review
as well that always helps us out
rankings we are the top conservative and
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
America
so demonstrating how leftist thought
leads to shortsightedness with regard to
fighting people even the left hates
there is an article in the new york
times over the weekend that's getting
all sorts of blowback and there's a guy
named tony Javed er you've never heard
of him because you're not a white
supremacist tony Javed er apparently is
on a show called radio Aryan he'll call
in to a show called radio Aryan and he's
the founder of some white supremacist
political party and he is he is a
full-on neo-nazi basically and there's
an article in the New York Times that
basically describes him as a regular guy
with horrific views what's funny is that
the left finds this particularly
repellents that how dare they describe
him as a regular guy in many ways with
disgusting political viewpoints as
though everyone who has disgusting
political viewpoints is you know a guy
with tattoos up his neck and a swastika
on his forehead like Charles Manson as
though people can't hide in plain sight
and as though people aren't moved from
mainstream political movements into
fringe political movements with relative
alacrity if you want to talk about the
risks of political extremism in the
country you have to acknowledge that
there's a group of regular people who
can easily be led astray by evil people
masquerading as quote-unquote normies
that's what this New York Times piece
does it says Tony and Maria Javed er
were married this fall they registered a
target on their list was a muffin pan a
four drawer dresser and a pineapple
slicer miss Javed her 25 was worried
about an Tifa bashing up the ceremony
weddings are hard enough to plan when
your fiance is not an avowed white
nationalist people very angry at this
how dare the New York Times say they
registered a target and pretend these
are normal people well because a lot of
people with evil beliefs mrs. zahana
rents entire theory right the banality
of evil is that evil people are people
who are evil they're not monsters so you
can identify easily and that's why you
have to be on your lookout that's the
whole point
I don't point to this article is that
you have to be on the lookout for people
like Tony Javed or because Javed er has
evil evil views but masquerades as a
normal person
right it says he is the Nazi sympathizer
next door polite and low-key at a time
the old boundaries of accepted political
activity can seem alarmingly in flux
most Americans would be disgusted in
baffled by his casually approving
remarks about Hitler to stay in for
democracy and belief that the races are
better off separate but as tattoos are
innocuous pop-culture references a slice
of cherry pie adorned
one arm and homage to the TV show Twin
Peaks okay so he's not you know he
sounds like a weirdo he's a welder and
they say that he's a regular guy who
just believes in Nazism basically he
says I don't think anyway he says I
don't want you to think I'm some edgy
Republican he says well flatly
denouncing the concept of democracy I
don't even think those things should be
edgy while defending his assertion Jews
run the worlds of Finance in the media
and appear to be working more in line
with their own interests than everybody
else's his political evolution from
vaguely leftist rock musician to ardent
libertarians of fascist activists was
largely fueled by the kinds of
frustrations that would not seem exotic
to most American conservatives so here's
the New York Times trying to tie him to
conservatism but the fact is that he did
at NC PAC apparantly in 2015 he named
rock people like Murray Rothbard who's
an anarcho-capitalist and and he had he
was a supporter of President Trump the
point of this article is not that he's a
good guy the point of this article is
that he's a very bad guy who believes
very bad things but can masquerade it in
plain sight and the reason that's
important is because listen I've dealt
with enough young college kids some of
whom have been seduced by the all right
to know that this is how they get
seduced they get seduced by the troller
II and then when people say well that's
really disgusting they say well you're
just politically correct I'll do more of
it they say well maybe the reason that
people are so opposed to my point of
view is because it's true maybe the
reason that people are so upset when I
post a holocaust meme is because the
Holocaust didn't really happened and
they know it and they're lying about it
this is how people get sucked in I mean
this guy's still young he's 25 years old
but it's it's pretty it's an in-depth
profile I think it's a very good profile
and the fact is that the left attacking
the profile is one of the reasons the
left is going to lose because by
attacking the profile that preventing
people from truly understanding how
these ideas materialize and that's
that's a that's a huge mistake okay time
for some things I like and then some
things I hate and then we will go
through a Federalist Papers so things I
like
over the weekend I watched an uplifting
film a great Thanksgiving Day film about
the Cambodian genocide it was actually
it's actually a very very good film so
Angelina Jolie made a she directed this
she helped write the screenplay it's an
adaptation of a nonfiction book by a
girl who was seven years old five and
then five to seven when the Cambodian
genocide took place that's called first
they killed my father
it actually is a good thing sniffing
giving movie just because be thankful
you do not live in a regime like this I
mean my god and be thankful it's
interesting Angelina Jolie tries to make
the rise of the Khmer Rouge about
basically the United States and how evil
the United States was for getting
involved in Cambodia in the first place
the truth is that the United States was
bombing the Khmer Rouge until they
decided to pull out of the Vietnam War
one of the things that happened after
the pullout from the Vietnam War was the
slaughter of over a million Cambodians
25% of the population was basically
murdered in Cambodia after the United
States pulled out of Vietnam and then
the Cambodians the Khmer Rouge went to
battle with the Vietnamese communists it
was there's actually a Russia China war
basically the Khmer Rouge were backed by
the Chinese
the Vietcong were backed by the the
Russians and they went to war the
Vietcong ended up winning that war the
Khmer Rouge were some of the worst
people ever to walk the planet and in
this film by Jolie Jolie had directed
the movie unbroken which is based on a
very good book by Laura Hillenbrand
about about a guy who's a prisoner of
war an American in Louise Zamperini a--
who's an American prisoner of war the
film itself is really pedestrian the
book is much better unbroken she's
picked up her game because this is
actually a pretty well directed film and
it's really it's it's a really effective
film it should be nominated for Best
Picture it probably will be she should
probably nominated for Best Director
which is a lot to say about somebody
like Angelina Jolie but it's it it's a
very effective film here's your some of
the preview Cambodia 1975 it's a little
girl everybody's gonna party
in from the US has good breath Bethenny
[Music]
so her father works for the Cambodian
government and and then has to hide who
he is it doesn't say for life both of
her parents are murdered in the film is
not a giveaway I mean the film is called
first they killed my father it's about
how these communists Orphic her
horrifying ideas destroying industry
there's it there's a really horrifying
scene where a guy his child is sick and
the Khmer Rouge won't let him use
quote-unquote Western medicine for his
child until goes out in steals Western
medicines they kill him it demonstrates
how horrific communism is and for all
the people I'm left who made way for
this kind of garbage for decades they
should be a not only ashamed
themselves they should live in in in a
constant state of penance for pretending
to the United States were the bad guys
when it came to the Vietnam War the
Vietcong were the bad guys the Khmer
Rouge were the bad guys the United
States were not the bad guys here movie
his first they killed my father and it's
well worth watching speaking of being
grateful for freedom this video is going
around last week and it really is truly
incredible this is a North Korean
soldier who attempts to defect and you
will see the North Koreans they they've
basically they built basically a wall to
keep people in they shoot this guy seven
times as he was trying to leave he
survived amazingly but here is the
here's some video of it they were just a
few feet behind him they fired more than
40 bullets but failed to kill or capture
him and tonight the North Korean
soldiers who couldn't keep their comrade
from pulling off a dramatic escape last
week are facing the fallout a South
Korean lawmaker tells CNN nearly all the
North Korean soldiers present along the
border that day have been replaced human
rights observers say being replaced
could be the least of their worries
meaning that they might be shot so this
guy actually ran away and he made it to
the other side if you have to you know
for all the people who are talking in
the United States these actresses and
actors talking about awfully America of
trumps elected you shut up it really
shut up the border is open you can leave
whenever you want it's fine go okay the
countries where the countries where
truly evil is going on they don't let
you leave they shoot you if you try to
leave okay other things that I like so I
want to say thank you to the New York
Times seriously they ran a very fair
piece from from a reporter named Sabrina
tavernas
who is actually I think a genuinely
objective reporter trying to do the
right thing Sherrod a piece called ben
shapiro a provocative gladiator battles
to win young conservatives it was a full
page article in the new york times over
over the Thanksgiving Day weekend it was
on Friday and the article I thought was
very fair they quoted some of my critics
I know that she had tried to reach out
to some of the people on the Left who
are my critics now some of them wouldn't
answer her but in any case this drove
left utterly insane and to demonstrate
just how intolerant the left are that
the left leftist are this is pretty
astonished they run this article that is
essentially an objective look at you
know our role here at the Daily wire in
the conservative movement what I do it's
about the podcast it talked about it at
length and I think it's a pretty fair
compelling look so Eric Bullard who's
just a scuzzbag beyond all skies bags
longtime nemesis day under bright Bart's
and Andrews to mock him for for being a
George Soros tool Erik Bullard
tweeted something out about how is a
puff piece on the former Breitbart
bottom feeder number of critics liberals
demo'd in peace zero well I mean you can
find leftist to criticize me all over
the Internet it really is not
particularly difficult including Eric
Butler this is my favorite part I was
trying to favor at this I only have one
favorite on Twitter it is Chris Evans
saying he genuinely dislikes me so I
really wanted to favorite this but Debra
Messing unfortunately blocked me Debra
Messing the the horrific actress from
Will and Grace has never been in
anything since since she can't actually
out of a paper bag but she tweeted out
that this article about me is why she
canceled her subscription to The New
York Times she actually canceled her
subscription to The New York Times
because they ran an objective article
about me
that wasn't a that wasn't a hit job so
one article about a conservative that
isn't a hit job in Debra Messing cancels
her subscription I mean to be fair I
thought her show Will & Grace is
absolute crap but I didn't cancel my
cable because of it I think she's a
terrible terrible actress but I didn't
like to say I'm not using TiVo anymore
so well done Debra Messing clear
apparently then she spent the weekend
painting a live horse or something so
I'm afraid that that article may have
driven her a little bit out of her mind
so I feel a little bit bad for that I'm
sorry Debra Messing that your life was
ruined by having to read views with
which you disagree I guess life is very
tough when their multi-million dollar
actress who hasn't made anything in 15
years and now is getting to be cast in a
reboot of your own garbage show in the
first place okay time for some things
that I hate
all right first thing that I hate I
meant to do this last week now I have to
do it there is a video that came out
showing professional cuddling I talked
about a little bit but I need to
actually show you the video of the
professional cuddling this is just
horrendous and never should happen in
the planet these are people who are
being hired to cuddle with other people
like strangers it says this person is a
total stranger to me her job is to give
people Huddle's she's a professional cut
list during their cut less session it's
it's a safe space it's a space where
they get through explore touch more
likely than not they're not getting the
level of touch that they need in their
everyday life I'm just about to go for
my very first company's session and
personally I have been going through a
tough time lately so I'm very curious to
see if this session will help me in any
way this is the session that starts by
setting some ground rules she asked you
to think about what you're most
comfortable with
as a first timer becoming relaxed wasn't
easy because why do you have any
strangers says how would you like me to
join you and she's like um I wouldn't
as I had to rely on this cuddle Sutra
book for inspiration okay okay no yes
it's pretty awkward okay then this goes
on it gets better with time though why
would you why why why why why sorry what
dude
okay so we're living in the society were
worried about sexual harassment and
sexual abuse you hire a professional cut
list a Rando to come over your house and
they're professional what makes you a
professional Cutlass like what makes you
good at this I'm just wondering do you
go to Cutlass school you get a PhD in
cuddling and what in the what in the
actual F okay get a boyfriend you know
get it get a dog like seriously people
you know what's happened we've sozin
we've so much separated sex and touch
from from emotion that now we're trying
to reach those things back together but
without actually forming emotional
connection with the person you have to
hire the person nor to cuddle you I mean
like when guys do used to do this it was
called a whorehouse when women do it
with other women then it's just cuddling
me there's nothing sexual going on I
guess but it's like it's a random person
that you're hugging like what in the
world and then we needed a tough enough
gang I think we're gonna need to toughen
up I'm not sure Western civilization can
survive the onslaught of reality if
you're hiring people to lie next to you
and cuddle you who you don't know what
in the world okay I had other things
that I hate but I'm sorry I have too
much hate for this I there's no more
room for others so now we're gonna do
Federalist number five so every Monday
we've been going through Federalist
paper gradually making our way through
all of the Federalist Papers in
Federalist number five is by John Jay
remember this beginning of the
Federalist Papers is all about why we
shouldn't be multiple nations as opposed
to one nation so John Jay talks about
how this would actually cause internal
dissension inside the nation what you
would actually end up with his wars on
the American continent between the
various nations on the continent he says
whenever and from whatever causes it
might happen and happen it would that
any one of these nations or
Confederacy's should rise on the scale
of political importance much above the
degree of her neighbors that moment with
those neighbors beholden with envy and
with fear in other words one region
would probably be stronger than the
other region and then you'd end up with
Civil War and he predicted that he in
this Federalist paper he basically
predicts the Civil War he says that the
North would probably out her in the
south and this would cause the South to
become jealous of the north and this
would cause the north to become
overreaching and then you would end up
with a with a war between the two sides
even if they were separate countries so
secession would not actually solve the
problem it would just end up leading to
war more easily now obviously he's not
talking about slavery here which was the
major issue in the Civil War but what
I'm saying is that he was predicting
conflict between North and South based
on regional differences and no national
Allegiance he says considering our
distance from Europe it would be more
natural for these Confederacy's to
apprehend danger from one another than
from distant nations and therefore the
each of them should be more desirous to
guard against the others by the aid of
foreign alliances than say guard against
foreign dangers by alliances between
themselves in other words the north and
the south wouldn't create an alliance
against Britain the north would ally
with with the French and the south would
ally with Britain and then they'd go to
war and then sooner or later you'd end
up with French and British troops on
American shores who are basically
serving the interests of one of the
regimes or the other and that's he'd get
a reinvasion of the United States by the
powers of Europe it's an interesting
argument it is also provocative in the
sense that it reminds us that a unified
foreign policy in the United States was
not a guarantee right there was a point
where it was not clear that the United
States was actually going to be the
United States it could have barely very
easily been the dis United States and
that would have led to a lot an awful
lot of bloodshed in fact the only time
when America tried to split apart it led
to the bloodiest war costing the most
number of lives in American history so
the founders knew what they were talking
about when they talked about the
necessity for uniting it also reminds us
that as much as we like to complain
about the divisions in the United States
right now they're the the divisions that
would be caused by some sort of
secession like a violent secession would
be a hell of a lot worse okay we'll be
back here tomorrow
lots more to discuss I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]